In this video, we'll discuss
the capacity of a single neuron.
That is the complexity of the
computations that it can perform.
Okay.
So we've seen before that,
uh, in two dimensions,
if we draw the,
uh,
output or the activation
of a given neuron,
there will look something
like this where we'll get, uh,
some rich between two parts of the space
where the Ridge is essentially defined
by the orientation of the is defined
by the vector w and the bias will also
determine the position of this rich.
So with a a neuron that performs a comp,
this type of computation,
we could perform binary
classification that is a,
if we use this sigmoidal,
uh, activation function,
we could interpret the activation of a
neuron as estimating the probability that
some input x belongs to the class one.
And so let's assume in
binary classification,
why can be either a zero or one and
then we could think of the output or the
activation of a neuron as giving us,
what's the estimate of the neuron that,
uh,
the input actually belongs to the category
one and then the problem that would
belong to the category. To, uh,
based on the Neuron Testament would just
be one minus this because probabilities
must sum to one.
And so we could do this if we use
a sigmoid because the sigmoid is a,
a bounded between zero and one.
And so we're always guaranteed that we
get at the output or the activation of a
neuron, a number which can be
interpreted as a probability.
So this in fact this exact form for
a classifier is known as a logistic
regression classifier.
And the way it's performing classification
is that if the output of the neuron,
so in other words,
uh,
if it's estimate of the probability
that x belongs to the class,
one is greater than 0.5,
then we will categorize the input into
the class or category one and otherwise
our classifier with output
prediction that the input belongs to,
um, the class zero. And so
if we were to draw this,
uh,
in two d than uh,
and if we looked at what is known
as the dishes decision boundary,
where the decision boundary is
essentially the surface where, uh,
the,
uh,
some input can equally belong to either
class zero or one could equally belong
to any two class, then what we
would get actually is that, uh,
the classifier is performing a
linear classification. That is,
it's drawing a line between two regions,
the regions that it's associates with
one class and the other region that
associates with the other class.
And just drawing a boundary
which is actually linear. So, uh,
in today's corresponds to align and in
more dimensions would correspond to a
hyper plane.
So if we have a problem where
we want to classify objects,
uh, described by input vectors
into two different classes,
if we can draw a hyperplane or align
into the between these two types of
objects, then a single artificial
neuron could do that for us.
It could model that type
of decision process.
So here's a few example of a simple
functions which can be modeled by a linear
classifier.
So if we have a binary inputs
that are either zero or one,
so we have [inaudible] that can be zero
one x two it can be zero one and then we
want to model the or function which
takes the aura of x one and x two so four
zero zero it would output a zero so that
will be class zero and for a one zero
one one or one or a zero
one it would output once.
So the triangles are
correspond to class one.
Well we can see that if we draw this,
we get easily pass align between all
the circles and all the triangles,
all the Zeros and all the
ones is another function,
a bit more complicated.
The end function over the
negation of x one and x two.
Uh,
then we get that all of these guys will
be of course zero and this will be a
class a one. And indeed, again,
we can pass a line between the two
classes and we have another example,
but instead of negation of x two where
we get a class one here and the others
are zero, again, we can
pass a straight line.
So these simple functions can easily be
modeled by a single artificial neuron.
However,
there are many problems in practice,
are not well separated
linearly and actually the are
very simple functions that
are not even uh, uh, linearly separable.
So there's an example of another
simple function, the x or function.
So this is a function
that outputs zero. If, uh,
either both inputs x one and x two are
zero or they're both one and it all the
outputs one.
So for these two guys,
when either one of the inputs are a one.
So in this case here,
we have one here we have zero four
at this point. And here at this one,
the x one is one and x two
is zero for this point.
And so in this case we see that we
cannot draw just a single line that would
actually separate, uh, on one side
all of the Zeros and on one side,
all the ones. So it's not linearly
separable. And yet it's a actually a very,
very simple problem.
So this suggests that a single artificial
neuron will not be sufficient for many
problems where we want to perform
this kind of binary classification.
However,
we noticed that it's such a simple
function that if we had instead plotted on
this axis deer result of applying the n
function over the negotiation of x one
and x two like we've seen
in the previous slide.
And on this axis we actually drew the uh,
we used as the value in this axis,
the output of the EMF function over
x one and the negation of x two.
Then this point and this point we
be collapsed over a single point.
And then this point would curse bond.
Now to that point and this point
to that point. And so in this case,
we could actually draw a single line
between the circles and the triangles
between the points associated with class
zero and the points associated with
class one.
So what this is saying is that if we get,
if we compute an alternate representation
or better representation of our input
vector, the problem might
become linearly separable.
And this also suggests that if we
have these, this other representation,
which is actually representable
by a single neuron,
and that's the case for this and function
in this and function we've seen before,
that we can actually model these
two functions by a single neuron.
Then this suggests that by having
other neurons connected by,
uh, other neurons, which would, uh,
so where we have a neuron that computes
this and around the compute stack,
if we connected these two neurons to
another neuron connected directly to these
artificial neurons here,
then we might be able to, uh,
compute a, uh, function,
a certain functions that
require more complicated, uh,
computations and a more
complicated decision surface.
And this will be the main intuition
behind developing more complicated a
multilayer neural networks,
which we'll see in the next video.